[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat bienvenue dans cette
édition spéciale une édition spéciale
consacrée aux discours de sur l'état de
l'union de jean claude juncker le
président de la commission européenne ce
matin devant les parlementaires
européens réunis à strasbourg dans
l'hémicycle à 9 heures s'est adressé
donc à ses confrères pour annoncer le
programme de la commission européenne
pour cette année break site bien entendu
mais aussi économie réforme des
institutions état de droit en rapport
avec la turquie
beaucoup de sujets dont je débattrai
tout à l'heure avec mes invités mais
tout de suite ces directions l'hémicycle
de strasbourg pour ce discours de jean
claude juncker à tout à l'heure
mister g dames monsieur le président
dans le même temps guillotine par les
messieurs les députés tout du fouilloux
10 times là est ce que je suis venu
prendre la parole au même mois l'année
dernière
mon discours était un peu plus facile
tout le monde
voyez que l'union était en piètre état
l'europe pour inverser une tempête un
choc et ses fondations mêmes on est
s'est ébranlé de choix nous avions une
possibilité car en tout cas de swat
nous nous unissions nous fixions au
nombre de jours positive constructive
ou alors chacun se replier dans son coin
triste rives destroy face à ce dilemme
j'ai défendu l'unité j'ai proposé des
projets constructifs pour contribuer à
créer je les dis le nez à nez une europe
qui protège qui assistent qui défend des
mois le parlement européen a contribué à
travailler à cet objectif
nous continuerons joue un jour
progresser lumière soir encore vous avez
ensemble travailler pour trouver un
accord sur les instruments de défense
commerciale
puis sur le doublement de notre capacité
d'investissement en europe et vous êtes
parvenus je vous en remercie je tiens à
remercier également les 17 dirigeants de
nos états membres
quelques jours après mon discours de
l'an dernier ils se sont félicités de
mes propositions lors du sommet de
bratislava qui ce faisant il hanté pour
lui noté ils ont choisi de travailler
ensemble ensemble
aussi nous avons montré que l'europe
être à la hauteur des choses dans
l'intérêt de ses citoyens lorsque les
ans j'étais détail depuis lors petit à
petit nous avons pris de l'élan les
perspectives économiques s'améliorer ce
qui nous attend dans la cinquième année
d'une reprise économique qui enfin se
fait sentir dans chaque état membre
la croissance dans l'union européenne a
dépassé celle des états unis lors des
deux dernières années dépasse maintenant
le % pour l'union dans son ensemble et
tous partout 2,2 pour cent pour le
chômage est au plus bas depuis neuf ans
huit millions d'emplois pratiquement en
fait écrit dès ce matin sauf à le depuis
le début de cette écriture 235 millions
d'européens dont un emploi ce qui fait
plus de personnes font dans l'union que
jamais auparavant de la commission
européenne la tournée européenne ne peut
certes pas être la seule à s'en
féliciter choix je signe à moins
convaincu que si huit mille neuf emplois
avaient été perdus
c'est la commission qui n'aurait été
accusé les institutions ont joué leur
rôle en contribuer au changement
nous pouvons changer notre plan européen
d'investissement qui a permis 225
milliards d'investissements
lee qui a permis de croiser des prêts à
plus de 445 1000 petites entreprises et
à plus de 270 projets d'infrastructures
nous pouvons nous féliciter les fêtes eu
grâce à l'inaction déterminer les
banques européennes une fois de plus sur
le capital nécessaire pour prêter aux
entreprises de centrales cela puisse
travailler et créer des emplois nous
féliciter d'avoir réduit déficit public
de 6 6% 1,6 pour cent
ceci s'est fait grâce à une application
intelligente du pacte de stabilité et de
croissance
nous avons demandé la disciplinaire
fiscales qu'elle met son prudent afin de
ne pas étouffer la croissance et ceci
fonctionne très bien partout dans
l'union
malgré certaines critiques dix ans après
la crise enfin rebondi et notre
confiance s'en ressent nourri ses
dirigeants le parlement et la commission
place l'europe sur les rails de l'union
et ensemble nous avons la consommer des
dirigeants se sont retrouvés sont app
store à rome tour de new davos et l'un
après l'autre ils ont répété leurs
engagements envers la communauté envers
l'union
et tout ceci m'a 6 à penser que l'europe
a de nouveau le vent en poupe
pendant nos occasions à saisir cette
occasion ne perdurera pas utilisons au
mieux c'est qu'ils ont poussé du vent
pour ceux ne vont faire deux choses
d'abord cet atlas
nous devons rester sur notre trajectoire
du nom reste encore 16 mois pendant
lequel nous pouvons progresser le
parlement le conseil la commission
peuvent aller de l'avant nous pouvons
utiliser ce temps dispositions pour
mettre un point final à ce que nous
avons
à bratislava et être à la hauteur dans
notre propre projet jeudi ensuite nous
devrions également donné des indications
sur l'avenir comme les mark twain et je
suis dans des plusieurs années ne seront
davantage déçu parce que nous n'avons
pas fait ou dit que parce que nous avons
fait il est temps maintenant
reconstruire ce que vous ne rope plus
unis plus fort et plus démocratique pour
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés alors que nous
regardons vers l'avenir
nous ne pouvons pas nous lasser dévier
notre cap
ensemble nous nous sommes fixés comme
objectif de paraphes avait une union de
l'énergie une union de la sécurité une
union des marchés des capitaux
une union bancaire et un marché unique
numérique
ensemble nous avons déjà fait bien du
chemin comme la consigne est votre
parlement
la commission a déjà présenté 80 % des
profs des propositions promise en début
de mandat nous devons maintenant
travailler ensemble pour que ses
propositions deviennent des actes
législatifs et que ces actes se
concrétise dans la pratique
comme toujours c'est une concession
devront être faites
les propositions présentées par la
commission pour réformer notre système
dans une commun ou pour établir de
nouvelles règles et des règles plus
solide sur le détachement des
travailleurs sont des sujets je le sais
contreversé nous obtiendrons de bons
résultats si chacun bâti sa partie du
pont pour que les positions puissent se
joindre
il voudrait dire que la comesa elle sera
ouverte au compromis
du moment que le résultat final est bon
pour l'union et équitable pour tous et
etam en nous sommes à mon prêt à
soumettre les 20% d'initiative restantes
ici mais 2018 ce matin et après c'est au
président du parlement et auprès
ministre estonien
bon je voudrais ici saluer l'action
forte qu'il est en train de déployer
pour ce qui est de l'europe
je viens de leur envoyer une lettre
d'intention précisant les priorités pour
l'année à venir
je ne vais pas et je ne peux pas vous
énumérer toutes ces propositions mais
permettez moi d'en mentionner 5 qui sont
pas tus et remonte importantes
premièrement je voudrais que nous
renforcions notre programme commercial
européen l'europe est ouverte au
commerce oui mais réciprocité il doit y
avoir il faudra que nous obtenions
autant que ce que nous donnons le
commerce n'est pas un concept abstrait
le commerce
ce sont des emplois ce sont de nouvelles
opportunités pour les entreprises
européennes grande ou petite mia
d'exportation en plus déplaisante 14
mille emplois supplémentaires
en novembre le commerce c'est
l'exploitation d'une aux normes sociales
et environnementales et du nord en
matière de protection des données ou de
sécurité alimentaire l'europe a toujours
été un espace économique attirant mais
depuis l'an dernier j'observe que nos
partenaires du monde entier se pressent
dans l'autre porte peut conclure des
accords commerciaux avec nous cazals est
de votre palm nous venons de conclure
avec le canada un accord commercial qui
s'applique là de manière provisoire à
compter de la semaine prochaine
nous avons trouvé un accord politique
avec le japon sur un futur partenariat
économique et d'ici la fin de l'année
nous avons de bonnes chances de faire de
même avec le pays avec le mexique et les
pays d'amérique du sud
aujourd'hui nous proposons d'ouvrir des
négociations commerciales avec
l'australie et la nouvelle-zélande
je voudrais que tous ces accords soient
finalisées d'ici la fin de ce mandat et
je tiens à ce qu'ils soient négociés
dans la plus grande transparence
l'ouverture aux défenses doit aller de
pair avec une transparence à plus de nos
processus décisionnel le parlement
européen aura le dernier mot sur
l'ensemble des accords commerciaux et
donc ses membres tout comme les
parlements nationaux et régionaux
doivent être tenues parfaitement
informés dès le premier jour des
négociations la commission hiver
dorénavant la commission publiera
l'intégralité des produits de mandat de
négociation cas présentera au conseil
les citoyens ont le droit de savoir ce
que propose la commission
fini le manque de transparence finies
les rumeurs et les procès d'intention
dont la commission des cesse de faire
l'objet
j'invite le conseil à faire de même
je veux dire une fois pour toutes nous
ne sont pas des partisans naïfs du libre
échange l'europe doit toujours défendre
ses intérêts stratégiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons aujourd'hui un nouveau câble
d'une européenne sur l'examen des
investissements il va s'inscrire en faux
ongles si une entreprise publique
étrangère veut acquérir un port européen
stratégique une partie de notre
infrastructure énergétique ou une de nos
sociétés santé madame ou une de nos
sociétés dans le monde dans le domaine
des technologies de défense
cela ne peut se faire que dans la
transparence à travers un examen
approfondi et un débat il est de notre
responsabilité politique de savoir ce
qui se passe chez nous afin d'être en
mesure si besoin on est de protéger
notre sécurité collectif
deuxièmement la commission voudrait
rendre notre industrie plus forte et
plus compétitif ce site en particulier
vrai que ce qui concerne notre base
industrielle et les 30 2 millions de
travailleurs qui ont constitué la
colonne vertébrale
ce sont eux qui fabrique les produits de
toute première classe
nos voitures par exemple auquel nous
devons notre avance par rapport à
d'autres
je suis fier de notre industrie
automobile mais je suis choquée qu'on
clients et consommateurs sont sciemment
et intentionnellement tromper
nous invite l'industrie automobile à
faire amende honorable et a corrigé le
tir
au lieu de chercher à tromper et a
induit en erreur les constructeurs
devraient investir dans les voitures
propres qui sont celles de demain nous
présente en nous présentant mesdames et
messieurs les députés aujourd'hui même
une nouvelle stratégie industrielle pour
l'europe qui permettra à notre industrie
de rester ou de devenir le numéro 1 en
matière d'innovation de numérisation et
de décarbonisation troisièmement je
voudrais que l'europe soit à
l'avant-garde de la lutte contre le
changement climatique
l'année dernière nous avons fixé des
noms climatique global avec la
ratification de l'accord de paris ici
même dans sept à son honneur face à
l'affaissement des ambitions dont fait
preuve en font preuve les états unis
l'europe doit faire en sorte de rendre
grant la planète qui la partie
indivisible de l'humanité tout entière
la commission présentera sous peu une
proposition de réduction des émissions
de carbone dans le secteur des
transports
et quatrièmement je voudrais que nous
quand ils ont mieux les européens à
l'ère du numérique au cours des
dernières années nous avons fait des
progrès notables dont la sécurisation de
l'internet de nouvelle règle proposée
par la commission
protégeons nos droits de propriété
intellectuelle
notre diversité culturelle et notent nos
données à caractère personnel
nous avons intensifié la lutte contre la
propagande terroriste et la
radicalisation en ligne mais l'europe
reste mal équipée face aux super
attaque les cyber attaques sont parfois
plus dangereuses pour la stabilité de
démocratie et des économies que les
fusils et que les chars bien que l'année
dernière on a enregistré plus de 4000
attaque taron essentielle et 80 % des
entreprises européennes ont connu au
moins un incident lié à l'as à la cyber
sécurité
les cyber attaques ne connaissent pas de
frontières elle les temps c'est pourquoi
la commission propose aujourd'hui de
nouveaux outils et notamment une agence
européenne de cybersécurité pour mieux
nous défendre contre ces attaques
et cinquièmement la migration doit
rester sur notre radar même si les
questions gravitant autour de l'arbre
mais grâce ou ont souvent suscité débats
et polémiques
nous sommes pas venus à faire de réels
progrès sur de nombreux plans
aujourd'hui nous protégeons nos
frontières extérieures des façons plus
efficaces plus de 10 700 officiers du
nouveau corps de gardes frontières des
garde côtes soutiennent maintenant les
cent mille gardes frontières nationaux
des états membres et patrie notamment en
grèce en italie en bulgarie et en
espagne nous avons des frontières
communes
mais les états membres qui sont entre
eux mais aline du fait la situation
géographique ne doivent pas être les
seuls responsables de leur protection
frontière commune et protection commune
doivent aller ensemble nous sommes pas
venus à endiguer les flux de mérite de
migrants irréguliers chausse de grandes
inquiétudes dans de nombreux pays nous
avons réduit les 97 % le nombre des
arrivées et rully en méditerranée
orientale
grâce à l'accord que nous avons conclu
avec la turquie
et cet été nous avons réussi à mieux
contrôler la voûte de la méditerranée
centrale
les arrivées qui ont diminué de 80 pour
cent en août par rapport au même mois de
l'année dernière
de cette manière nous avons
considérablement réduit le nombre des
vies perdues en méditerranée je ne peux
pas parler de migration sans rendre un
hommage appuyé à l'italie pour sa
persévérance et sa générosité
cet été
pendant les mois d'été la commission a
travaillé en toute harmonie avec le
premier ministre italien mon ami par le
jeune polonais et son gouvernement
nous l'avons fait et nous continuons à
le faire parce que en méditerranée
l'italie sauf l'honneur de l'europe
nous devons aussi et de toutes les
urgences améliorer les conditions de vie
des réfugiés en libye
je suis atterré par les conditions
humaines inhumaine qui prévalent dans
les centres de rétention
hudak est ici l'europe a une
responsabilité mais une responsabilité
collectif et la commission agira de
concert avec les nations-unies pour
mettre fin à cette situation scandaleuse
qui ne peut durer
même si ça m'attriste de voir que tous
nos états membres ne montre pas le même
degré de solidarité
l'europe leur prise dans son ensemble à
continuer à faire preuve de solidarité
bien que l'année passée nos états
membres ont accordé l'asile à plus de
720 mille réfugiés ou encore pourvus
alors et installations c'est trois fois
plus que sur l'australie le canada et
les états unis
prises ensemble l'europe l'europe
contrairement à ce qui est dit n'est pas
une forteresse et ne doit jamais le
devenir
l'europe est et restera le continent de
la solidarité où doivent pouvoir trouver
refuge
ceux qui sont pour lui que de raison
inacceptable je suis
je suis parti à mencière des jeunes
européens qui se portent volontaires
pour donner des cours de langues aux
réfugiés syriens ou de tous ces jeunes
qui par milliers se sont mis au service
et notre nouveau corps rien de
solidarité ces jeunes-là donne vie et
couleurs à la solidarité européenne
aujourd'hui
mais nous devons redoubler d'efforts à
la fin du mois la commission présente
dans une nouvelle série de propositions
centre est gelé le tour la solidarité
avec l'afrique et l'ouverture des voies
l'immigration légale concernant plus
particulièrement les retours je voudrais
répéter que les personnes qui ne sont
pas en droit de séjourner en europe
doivent regagner leur pays d'origine
alors que seulement 36 % des migrants en
situation irrégulière sont renvoyés il
est évident que nous devrons
considérablement intensifié notre effort
et notre action en la matière
c'est seulement de cette manière que
l'europe pourra faire preuve de
solidarité à l'égard des réfugiés qui
ont réellement besoin de protection
la solidarité ne peut pas être une
affaire exclusivement entre européenne
il s'agit aussi de mettre en place une
plus grande solidarité avec l'afrique
afrique berceau de l'humanité continent
noble continent jeune notre fonds
fiduciaire pour l'afrique
doté d'une enveloppe de 2 7 milliards
d'euros ouvre des possibilités dans le
voit partout sur le continent africain
mais alors que le budget de l'union
européenne à assumer le gros du
financement
la contribution de tous nos états
membres réunis
mais ces lettres 450 millions d'euros le
fonds atteint maintenant ses limites
nous connaissons nous devrions connaître
les risques d'une pénurie de
financements en 2015 de nombreux
migrants ont voulu rejoindre l'europe
quand et parce que les fonds du
programme alimentaire mondial de l'onu
se sont épuisés j'invite donc les etam
en rejoindre le geste à la parole et à
veiller à ce que le fonds fiduciaire
pour l'afrique ne connaisse pas le même
sort
le risque est grand
nous allons aussi travailler à
l'ouverture des voies de migration
légale la migration irrégulière ne
s'arrêtera que lorsque les migrants
auront une autre option est
d'entreprendre un voyage périlleux
nous sommes ils sont sur le point très
installé 22 mille réfugiés venant de
turquie de jordanie ou du liban et je
m'associe à l'appel on sait pas le haut
commissaire des nations unies pour les
réfugiés que réinstaller quarante mille
autres réfugiés originaires de libye et
des pays voisins pour le reste europe
est un continent qui vieillit
raison de plus pour le doter d'un
système d'immigration illégale qui est
une nécessité incontournable
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
commission avait des propositions pour
faciliter l'accès des migrants
la carte bleue européenne et je remercie
l'allemand de son soutien à cet égard
j'ai fait dans la présidente du fn dame
du tissu le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés en vinyle chaque
livre je n'ai par les sites sûrs du
monde certains des initiatives que nous
allons devoir mener à terme leur des
seize mois venir tous pris une portée
allant battre
ceci ne suffira pas les jeux d'hiver si
nous voulons atteindre à sur les coeurs
des européens au delà de la récréation
d'un cérébrale il y tombe il entrait qu
il reste au contact de définir le match
la commission a présenté son livre blanc
sur l'avenir de l'europe qui contient 15
scénarii présentant ce que pourrait être
l'europe en 2010
ces scénarii ont été débattus parfois
superficiellement souvent vivement ont
été analysés et ça les chiffres rouges
et c'est très bien parce que c'est
précisément de la sorte qu'il faut
procéder
je voulais lancer un processus de
réflexion 40 en europe et qui même de
réfléchir à leur avenir et l'avenir de
l'europe
il ne peut pas être dicté par le haut de
telles décisions doivent se fonder sur
un bel acte démocratique sur un
consensus large place
ce parlement a beaucoup contribué à ce
débat et je tiens d'ailleurs à remercier
tout particulièrement les rapporteurs je
voudrais également remercier les
collègues qui voudront participer à plus
de 2000 consultation de la commission a
organisé depuis le mois de mars partout
en europe
il est temps maintenant de tirer les
premières conclusions de ces débats il
est temps d'entreprendre une démarche
suivante il faut passer des paroles aux
actes des débats aux décisions du site
je voudrais si vous présentez un des
aspects les sexes canard c'est ce que
j'appellerais personnellement le sixième
scénario de route scénario se fonde sur
une expérience personnelle de plusieurs
décennies
ma vie entière rhdp jeu j'ai baigné dans
le projet européen tout à fait de cap j
y travaille et je n'ai défendu les
vaches grasses j'étais plusieurs côtés
de la table des négociations en temps
communistes premier ministre président
du groupe éponyme a prise dans la
commission hamas
j'étais à maastricht amsterdam des
sinistres
cette rentrée quand au fur et à mesure
que notre union se développe et
s'élargissent et et j'ai toujours lutté
pour leur est parfois j'ai souffert de
l'europe et j'en ai douté j'ai connu des
hauts et des bas avec une européenne
mais est toujours gardé le même amour
pour l'europe nous le savons on en poche
il n'y a pas d'amour sans désamour en
tout cas très rares mais oui l'amour
d'europe parce que l'europe l'union
européenne atteint quand même quelque
chose d'unique dans un monde déchiré la
paix en son sein la paix dans sa
politique intérieure le bien n'est fait
je ne ferai pas pour tous du coup
beaucoup 2018 devrait être ce qu'on
suivrait moi ce moment là comme l'année
de l'héritage du patrimoine européen
2010 doit être la fête de la diversité
culturelle européenne des verts tu es de
bonne de drague europe le multi
culturelle de l'europe ont fait pour
nous par foyer sur pour moi l'europe ce
n'est pas le marché intérieur l'argent
l'euro il s'agit avant tout de valeur 6e
scénario se font de l'ombre sur trois
principes de base auquel il est
impossible de renoncer
la liberté l'égalité de droit et l'état
de droit que l'europe est avant tout à
une union de liberté je pense enfin la
liberté de l'oppression et de la
dictature
notre continent n'a connu que trop bien
notamment les pays d'europe centrale et
orientale la liberté la liberté
d'expression en tant que citoyen en tant
que journaliste
[Applaudissements]
s'ils trouvent souvent est considérée
comme acquise et notre union a été
fondée sur ses libertés et mamie la
liberté ne va pas de soi il faut se
battre pour cette liberté en europe dans
le monde
l'europe doit être une union de
l'égalité de droits parce que tout ceci
revient à dire égalité droits entre ses
membres on se moque la petit ou grand à
l'ouest de vigo jusqu'avant la wrta
l'espagne en bulgarie europe pas mousse
l'europe plus de respirer à pleins
poumons à l'est et à l'ouest
autrement notre continent s'essoufflera
dans une union
dgo il ne peut pas y avoir deux
ressortissants de deuxième classe
il est inadmissible qu'en 2010 est
encore des enfants meurent de maladies
qui aurait depuis longtemps dû
disparaître de notre continent
dans les domaines une connerie tu tes
enfants roumanie en italie devraient
avoir accès au vaccin
les crimes des commandes les enfants
dans d'autres pays de rhône sans
condition aucune paix dans le monde
renault travaillons avec tous les états
membres pour que les 200 panneaux
nations les vaccinations phrases sont
unis val il faut éviter les morts et que
l'on peut éviter en europe
il a au nom de l'union entre égaux voire
de travailleurs même si de 2e classe et
du rail à battre ce qui fit eu le même
travail au même endroit pouvoir obtenir
le vin de salaire
les fils d'in de commission reproche la
commission a dans ce sens fait les
propositions sur le détachement des
travailleurs
nous devrions veiller à ce que toutes
les dispositions de lorient concernant
la mobilité des travailleurs soient
justes efficaces et imposer partout avec
le soutien d'une nouvelle autorité
européenne de contrôle et d'exécution de
ces mesures
il est absurde s'il est une autorité
bancaire qui veille à ce que les normes
bancaires sont respectés c'est saab
sorte dans un bikini pains d'autorité
des communes du marché de l'emploi
assurant la justice sur le marché
interne
j'avais peur de nous là créeront dans
une union entre égaux il ne veut pas non
plus avoir de consommateurs de deuxième
classe accepté je ne peux que dans
certaines parties de l'europe
quand elle est appelée en europe de
l'est dans des aliments de moins bonne
qualité soient vendus
d'ailleurs alors que l'emballage et
l'étiquetage sont identiques
les slovaques ont le droit d'avoir la
même quantité de poissons et dans l'eure
bâtonnets de poisson
les hongrois ont droit à la même
quantité de viande dans des plats
cuisinés et les tchèques ont droit
humain quantité de cacao dont le
chocolat le droit de l'union interdit
aujourd'hui déjà de telles pratiques
nous devons maintenant les compétences
nécessaires pour que nous puissions
partout en europe lutter contre ces
pratiques illégales
d'être enfin en europe des marques à ce
régime nous appliquons la force et en
digital de la loi de moore ils n'ont la
loi du plus fort tu as peut-être ceci
revient à dire que le droit et la loi
doivent être garantis pas une justice
indépendante parti l'union fondée sur
l'état de droit revient à dire accepter
les jugements les respecter
quitte à long terme des états membres
ont décidé de céder à la cour européenne
de justice
les décisions en dernière instance les
arrêts de la cour de justice
ils doivent être respectés
systématiquement ne pas les respecter
saper l'indépendance des tribunaux
nationaux revient à bip a privé les
européens de leurs droits fondamentaux
l'état de droit n'est pas une option sur
l'union européenne
elle est l'état de grâce est
contraignant à notre union mais pas un
état mais elle est dans un état de droit
des dragons ces trois principes liberté
et égalité de droit état de droit doit
être vrai c'est la base sur laquelle
nous appuyons pour construire une union
plus forte que démocratie lorsque nous
parlons de notre avenir fait de même
chez les ch'tis mon expérience me permet
de vous dire que de nouveaux traités de
nouvelles institutions ne pas forcément
la réponse apportée à nos concitoyens
ils sont simplement une façon d un des
moyens pour une fin pour nous peut-être
c'est important on leur donnait de là à
bruxelles à strasbourg
mais par ailleurs débat la déco les
réformes institutionnelles ne
m'intéresse que celle permettent de
rendre l'union plus efficace top souffle
au lieu de se réfugier dans de futures
modifications de traités qui devront se
faire un jour il faudrait d'abord
essayer de nous détourner de l'idée que
d'aucuns doivent perdre pour que les
autres puissent gagner la démocratie
fonctionne par compromis et les bons
compromis à tout le monde dit non mur
antennes les compromis ne sont ni
négative ni obscène son clar vrai que de
surmonter les oppositions pour se
rapprocher les uns des autres et qui
n'avait fait ça à accepter les compromis
sont incompatibles avec la démocratie et
son europe incompatibles et rail shooter
afin de renforcer son unité
l'union européenne doit également être
plus inclusive denechaud si nous voulons
renforcer la protection des frontières
et sérieux à juste titre mais rejetèrent
qu'il y en ait davantage encore l'avenir
mais nous devons absolument ouvrir
l'espace schengen à la roumanie et à la
bulgarie plus d'efforts de shining
devient également permettre à la croatie
d'adhérents tient à l'espace chine dès
que tous les critères auront été
remplies nous voulons que l'euro
unissent davantage en 30 ans qui n'ont
rien de nausées l'euro ne devrait être
la devise certains pays et l'ue le
destin de l'europe est de devenir la 2e
tout européenne et à tous et à mon sauf
deux ont le droit et le devoir adhérer à
la zone euro dès qu'ils en auront entre
les conditions mais des états membres
qui souhaitent adhérer à la zone euro
tout doit pouvoir le faire voici
pourquoi je propose de créer un
instrument de pré adhésion à l'euro qui
attendent car ces pays les techniques
voire financière
[Applaudissements]
nous voulons les banques partout sur
notre continent fonctionne dans le
respect des mêmes règles et sous la
houlette des les autorités de
supervision
il faudrait encourager tous les états
membres de l union bancaire
c'est l'fun il nous faut réduire les
risques qui subsistent dans le système
bancaire de certains instruments venus
bancaire ne fonctionne que si nous
réduisons et partageant les risques et
ceci afin d'y parvenir
chacun de ces appels des conditions
préalables
ce sont ces faits la commission a
proposé m euros en 2015
il faut même à garantie de placement et
ceci n'est possible que si chacun fait
ses devoirs
chez soi dans son cas si nous voulons
mettre fin à l'éclatement social
shopping social en europe des socios
membres devraient le plus vite possible
et au plus tard lors du son des gâteux
pas en novembre se mettre d'accord sur
le pilier européen des droits sociaux
des systèmes sociaux nationaux resteront
longtemps différentes et indépendantes
mais nous devrions au moins nous mettre
d'accord sur union européenne des normes
sociales au sein de laquelle un
consensus sur ce qui est socialement
injuste fikin juste sur notre marché
intérieur
[Applaudissements]
je reste convaincu david riley que
d'offre si l'europe doit réussir
elle ne doit pas tourner le dos aux
travailleurs madame et messieurs si nous
voulons davantage de stabilité dans
notre voisinage
nous avons également besoin d'offrir une
perspective d'élargissement fiable pour
les balkans occidentaux
vers un président comme une sauce une
par la mer alors que nous sommes à mi
mandat de la savons qu'il n'y aura pas
de révision parce que les conditions de
design pourront pas être remplis mais
l'union européenne contre 1 dans les
années à venir plus de 27 et amanda
mais chaque fois pour chaque pays
candidat
il faut que l'état de droit la justice
et les valeurs fondamentales soient
respectés c'est une priorité ou soft 4k
ceci pour l'instant une adhésion de la
turquie türk à la turquie depuis
quelques temps pour 2 s'éloigne très
vite de l'union européenne à pas de
géant tous les journalistes comme des
dizaines d'autres dans des rédactions
qui doivent pouvoir s'illustrer musée
gourmand
les journalistes ne peuvent pas se
retrouver en prison
[Applaudissements]
j'adresse aujourd'hui un appui un appel
aux responsables
libérez nos journalistes et pas que les
nôtres c'est insulter nous états membres
nos chefs d'état et de gouvernement les
traitant de fascistes et de nazis hop un
continent de démocratie mûre mais ce qu
ici à man insultes
toutes les possibilités de jeter
l'épongé des fois j'ai l'impression que
certains en turquie veulent couper les
ponts et ponceaux ultérieurement accusé
l'union européenne de l'échec des
discussions d'adhésion notre part nous
resterons toujours l'un à 102 pour le
grand peuple turc et pour tous ceux qui
sur la base de 20 de nos valeurs veulent
travailler avec nous j'aimerais bien que
notre rayon confort et à cette fin des
requins nous devons renforcer le marché
intérieur
je voudrais que sur des questions
importantes du marché intérieur mais
nous puissions plus rapidement et plus
facilement décidé au conseil en majorité
qualifiée avec droit à la même hauteur
du parlement à cette fin il ne faut pas
nous modifier les traités que le traité
contient sont maintenant des
dispositions ton qui permet dans
certains cas des conditions colosse
concert opine le denier le désir décide
à la majorité de décider ultérieurement
à la majorité il faut que le conseil je
répète le décide d'abord dans un présent
à l'unanimité je suis pas fier je suis
pas pourquoi une décision qualifiée sur
une assiette sur l'assiette fiscale sur
la tva sur l'économie mobilisés sur un
imposant une relation financière à la
majorité qualifiée doivent pouvoir
décider au plus vite
elle doit être plus efficace or ceux ci
ont aussi besoin de faire une annonce
faite dans le cadre économique et
monétaire qui doit être plus efficace
euros et plus résistant qu'il ya
quelques années nous avons notamment mis
en place le mécanisme de stabilité
je pense à petit devenir un fonds
monétaire européen qui doit cependant
être solidement ancrée dans le corps de
règles gérant de la commission en
décembre fort des propositions concrètes
dans ce sens il nous faut dix ministres
européens de l'économie et des finances
un ministre européen qui soutiendrait
des réformes structurelles positive dans
nos états membres
il pourra se fonder sur le travail que
la commission a effectué depuis 2015
fallait que son unité dédiée au soutien
des réformes structurelles le ministre
de l'économie et des finances devraient
coordonner tous les instruments de
financement de l'union qui doivent être
mises en place pour qu'un état membre
puisse se sortir d'une crise grave où il
opérait de récession
je ne voudrais pas que l'on créé un
nouveau poste je demande pour des
raisons d'efficacité que le commissaire
chargé des arts et l'économie et les
finances
monsieur il ya serait d'en faire un ex
président de la commission européenne
devienne sinistré soit également le
district président de l'eurogroupe les
ministres européens de l'est comme des
finances doit bien entendu être
responsable devant le parlement européen
nous n'avons pas besoin de structures
parallèles ne faut pas un budget à part
de la zone euro il nous faut une
immunitaire forte de l'eurozone dans le
cadre de notre budget de l'union des
deux ne me convainc guère le parlement
deux autres c'est ce parlement européen
[Applaudissements]
notre devenues plus fortes pour lutter
contre le terrorisme
pourquoi bien des années nous avons
beaucoup progressé dans la matière aussi
mis dans le cas de menaces terroristes
transfrontalières
nous ne sommes pas assez rapides je
plaide donc pour la mise en place d'une
unité d'intelligence européenne qui
veillerait à ce que les données sur les
terroristes et sur les combattants
étrangers soient automatiquement
transmises entre nos services de police
et et d'information
à mon avis il s'agit d'un site a confié
au procureur au t1 la possibilité de
poursuivre les actes terroristes
transfrontalières
l'union européenne note également peser
davantage sur l'échiquier mondial
pour ce faire ou si elle va pouvoir
rapidement contre décisions en matière
de politique étrangère voici pourquoi je
demande aux états membres de vérifier
quelles décisions de politique étrangère
on ne devrait plus être prise à
l'unanimité mais à la majorité qualifiée
le traité et l'autorisent si dans un
premier temps le conseil européen
français décision annule l'audit il faut
en matière de politique étrangère être
plus efficace et pouvoir décider à la
majorité
[Applaudissements]
d'autres efforts s'imposent la création
d'un fonds européen de défense est à
l'ordre du jour la coopération
permanente structuré en matière de
défense est bien lancée d'ici 2025
il nous faudra une union de la défense
qui fonctionne de l'émission nous en
avons besoin et l'otan lémery beaucoup
enfin la commission scolaire
je voudrais dans le droit fil des
efforts de la commission de ces
dernières années puisque une autre
réunion se concentre davantage sur ce
qui est vraiment important
nous ne devrions pas en souvenir les
citoyens européens sont des mâles de
petit fail mais nous devrions donner les
grandes orientations nous ne voyons pas
sans cesse annoncée dans les petites
initiatives mais nous devrions permettre
aux états membres d'en récupérer les
capacités et les compétences solides
alors voici pourquoi la commission a
essayé de faire preuve de grandeur dans
les granges et et de se retirer sur des
petits projets de la commission a
présenté par année moins de 25 nouvelles
initiative alors que lors des
commissions qui m'ont précédé avait plus
de sens du jeu ils nous ont bien en
mettre un point final au travail qui
avait été il faudrait une nouvelle tâche
fort subsidiarité fonctionnalités mais
cet imam chargera de cette ce groupe qui
accueillera également des députés de ces
parlements et des parlements nationaux
ils nous feront rapport le sud en un an
mais le président mesdames messieurs
notre union a besoin d'un saut
démocratique
je souhaiterais que les partis
politiques européens lancent leur
campagne que les projections élections
européennes plutôt que par le passé trop
souvent les campagnes électorales
européennes ont été réduite à une simple
addition des propositions électorales
nationales la démocratie européenne
mérite mieux
aujourd'hui la commission propose du net
de nouvelles règles sur le financement
des partis et des fondations politiques
il ne s'agit pas de renflouer les
caisses des extrémistes qui sont contre
l'europe
il s'agit de permettre aux partis
européens de mieux pouvoir s'articuler
je n'ignore pas que l'idée est contestée
a plus que quelques-uns mais je dois
vous dire que j'ai de la sympathie pour
l'idée de présenter des listes front
national aux élections et j'essaierai de
convaincre le président de mon groupe
parlementaire de me suivre dans cette
ambition qui ajoute la démocratie et de
la clarté
je pense également qu au cours des
prochains mois nous devrions associer
les parlements nationaux et la société
civile au niveau national régional et
local ou travaux sur l'avenir d'europe
au cours des trois dernières années les
membres la commission
comme nous l'avions promis ont rendu
visite aux parlements nationaux a plus à
plus de 650 entreprises
ils ont participé à plus de trois son
dialogue avec les citoyens dont plus de
4 dans 80 villes dans 27 états membres
c'est pourquoi je soutiens l'idée du
président macron d'organiser des
conventions démocratique dans toute
l'europe en 2018 à mesure que le débat
se développera j'accorderai une
attention particulière à l'estonie la
lettonie la lituanie qui à la romagne et
2018 est l'année où ces quatre pays
célébreront le centième anniversaire ce
qu'ils ont pour ambition de façonner
l'avenir de notre continent
ce client pour ambition de façonner
l'avenir de notre continent doivent
connaître et on aurait notre histoire
commune et donc l'histoire des quatre
pays mentionnés sont lesquels l'union
européenne ne serait pas compliquer le
besoin de renforcer la démocratie et la
transparence a évidemment des
conséquences pour la commission
européenne aujourd'hui je transmets au
parlement européen un nouveau code de
conduite des commissaires
tout d'abord ce nouveau code précise que
les commissaires peuvent se présenter
dans des conditions normales qu'on
candidats aux élections européennes
évident que le nouveau code ou en
forcera les obligations des commissaires
en matière d'intégrité pendant et après
le monde qui veut renforcer la
démocratie européenne ne peut pas
accepter que le petit progrès
démocratique que constitue à
l'innovation de cette liste de cinq
candidats ne soit pas renouvelée je
voudrais que l'expérience soit poursuivi
et je ne serai pas candidat présentez
vous mais vous ne serez pas du plus plus
de démocratie veut dire plus
d'efficacité
la fiq a cité européenne il y en aurait
en force
si nous pouvions fusionner les
présidences du conseil européen et de la
commission européenne
cette proposition ne visons rien mon ex
l'on a mis des notes avec qui le
collaborent harmonieusement et en
intimité de complicité depuis le début
de notre mandat
sa proposition ne vise ni données ni moi
même le paysage europe 1 ce serait tout
simplement plus lisible plus
compréhensible si le navire européen
était pilotée par un seul capitaine de
l'as fait d'avoir un seul président
l'efs les deux les mieux la véritable
nature notre union européenne à la fois
communion des états et communion des
citoyens
mes chers collègues la vision d'une
europe plus unie plus forte plus
démocratique que je présente aujourd'hui
associé des éléments de tous les
scénarii que je vous ai exposé le en
mars dernier mais notre avenir ne peut
pas rester un simple scénario une
esquisse une idée parmi d'autres
c'est aujourd'hui que nous devons
préparer union de demain j'ai envoyé ce
matin aux présidentes ihany aux prisons
tout ce qu ainsi qu'aux future
présidence tournante du conseil d'ici à
mars 2019 une feuille de route indiquant
la direction que nous devions suivre
sont importantes
à cet égard les propositions budgétaires
que la commission présentera en mai 2010
beach là encore nous avons le choix soit
nous cantonnons les ambitions de l'union
européenne dans le cadre strict du
budget actuel soit nous augmentons la
capacité budgétaire de l'union
européenne pour qu'elle puisse mieux
répondre à ses ambitions
je suis pour la deuxième solution
le 20 9 mars 2019
le royaume uni qui tu là l'union
européenne ce sera à la fois un moment
triste et tragique nous le regretterons
toujours et vous le regretterez bantous
mais nous devons respecter la volonté du
peuple britannique
mais nous allons avancer nous allons
avancer parce que le break site l'est
pas tout parce que le break ce n'est pas
le but de l'europe
le 3 mars 2019 nous serons d'une union à
je propose que nous il que nous nous y
préparons bien des élections parlement
européen auront lieu à peine quatre
semaines plus tard on mai 2019
ce serait un rendez vous important avec
la démocratie européenne
il faudra que les citoyens européens
seront aux urnes en ayant une vision
claire de la manière dont l'union
européenne évoluera dans les années à
venir
c'est pourquoi nous j'en appelle au
président tous et à la roumanie qui
exercera la présidence au cours du
premier semestre 2010 9 d'organiser un
sommet spécial en roumanie le 30 mars
mon bois mon voeu serait que ce sommet
se tienne dans la belle ville de sibiu
aussi connu sous le nom de hermann ce
ladder était le moment de nous réunir
pour prendre les décisions nécessaires à
la construction d'une europe plus unie
plus forte plus démocratique
on a espoir que le 30 mars 2009 des
européens se réveilleront dans une union
où nous défendrons toutes nos valeurs ou
tous les états n'en respecte sans nuance
l'état de droit ou un membre à part
entière de la zone euro de l'union
bancaire c'est l'espace schengen sera
devenu la norme pour tout un chacun
où nous aurons consolider les fondements
de notre union économique et monétaire
avant de pouvoir afin de pouvoir
défendre notre monnaie unique en toutes
circonstances bon ou mauvais ce sans
avoir à recourir à une aide extérieure
et où notre marché unique sera plus
équitable pour les travailleurs de l'est
comme de l'ouest
je voudrais que les européens puissent
se réveiller
dans une europe où nous aurons réussi à
nous mettre d'accord sur un solide socle
des normes sociales ou les bénéfices
seront imposées là où ils sont réalisés
ou les terroristes ne trouveront aucune
faille est exploitée et où sont mis
d'accord sur la création d'une véritable
union européenne de la défense où un
président unique conduira à terme les
travaux de la commission du conseil
européen après avoir été élu à l'issue
d'une campagne électorale européenne de
démocratique
monsieur le président si le 30 mars 2019
nos citoyens se réveille dans cette
union la l'union européenne sera une
union qui aura répondu à leurs attentes
justifiée mesdames et messieurs les
députés m ou de colle et jacques delors
que j'ai eu l'honneur de côtoyer m'ont
appris que l'europe n'avance quelques
rangs elle fait preuve d'audace le
marché unique
les stations la monnaie unique
voilà des idées et des projets qui ont
été considérés lorsqu'ils furent n'est
comme de simples vues à ce prix pourtant
aujourd'hui ses trois réalisations
mazars font partie de notre quotidien
maintenant que leur vaut mieux promet
dit qu'il ne faut pas surcharger la
barre européenne
mais il ne faut pas à l'heure où nous
sommes péché par excès de prudence
nous sommes en train de réparer le toit
de l'europe
mais aujourd'hui et demain nous devons
pas serment
étage par étage moment après maman
inspiration après inspiration continuer
à ajouter de nouveaux étages à la maison
des rocs il faut parachever la maison
europe
maintenant qu'il fait beau et tant qu'il
fait beau parce que quand les nuages se
forment monde à l'horizon et ils vont se
fournit un jour il aura été trop tard
alors larguant les amarres la haine l'os
comme disent les armes
maintenant les voiles et profitant des
vents favorables
je vous remercie de votre attention
l'argon les amarres mettons les voiles
et profitons des vents favorables un
discours dans qui donne le ton un ton
résolument optimiste pour le président
de la commission européenne ce qui nous
change de ces dernières années il est en
fait de construire l'europe de demain ne
pas achever de construire les étages
discours très dense plusieurs annonces
d'envergure jean claude juncker là on
sent il ya une envie de construire et je
vais en parler avec mes invités il en
est fini selon lui de la décennie noire
de l'union européenne s'est finie la
crise il est temps donc de construire
l'europe de demain pour décrypter
isabelle jégouzo bonjour bonjour vous
êtes chef de la représentation de la
commission européenne à paris c'est bien
ça absolument que c'est l'équivalent en
fait d'ambassadrice un petit peu un
petit peu en face de vous passer adjoint
alain directrice générale de la
fondation robert schuman bienvenus enfin
philippe ricard vous êtes journaliste au
monde vous avez été correspondant à
bruxelles pendant presque dix ans mais
c'est ça et vous êtes chef adjoint du
service étranger quelques mois peut-être
sur ben justement le ton ce discours
isabelle jégouzo alors on va parler de
votre chef
mais c'est vrai que ça nous change un
petit peu du ton un peu morne de ces
dernières années on sent qui a
résolument un peu un regain d'optimisme
clairement clairement une commission
volontaire une commission ambitieuse qui
veut avancer qui veut d'abord montré que
pendant toutes ces années difficiles
pendant ces années du raïs où on a dix
ans de crise où on allonge est né il ya
deux ans on était dans la clé des
réfugiés dans la crise grecque la un
dernier était dans le vrai qu site
et là on a montré que quand même en
avait eu des résultats des résultats
économiques en termes de croissance la
croissance de l'union européenne est
supérieure à celle des états unis en
termes d'emploi on n'a jamais eu autant
de
salariés d'emploi dans l'union
européenne même si il ya encore du
travail à faire donc on a travaillé et
aujourd'hui on commence à recueillir les
fous les fruits de ce travail ce travail
et donc il ya autre chose du coup il ya
un autre une autre séquence il faut il
ya une séquence politique qui est
clairement plus faveur
l'élection d' emmanuel macron d'enfin
normalement à la fin de la semaine
prochaine
angela merkel si toutefois les sondages
sont les bons devrait être réélu pour un
quatrième mandat ça veut dire que là il
va s'ouvrir aussi une séquence qui va
pouvoir permettre autre chose on est à
la fois dans la nécessité de continuer à
travailler sur ce qu'on a entamée il ya
eu des annonces ce matin en matière de
commerce en matière de démocratie
et puis il ya aussi des annonces à long
terme avec la volonté de construire
cette europe à vingt-sept puisqu'avec le
bras le brésil et on va y revenir
effectivement parce qu'à ce jour là
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé à moi
j'aime beaucoup les illusions marine
c'est très drôle pour un luxembourgeois
qui n'a pas de côtes maritimes
non j'ai cru qu'ils avaient beaucoup
d'audace dans le discours de
de jean claude juncker c'est à dire que
il se rend compte en effet qu'on arrive
à l'instant t comme l'a rappelé avec
zizou n'a en effet des vents favorables
notamment en matière économique
ce qui était loin d'être le cas que
l'euroscepticisme sans être complètement
dit avoir disparu a quand même été
sérieusement mise à mal par plusieurs
élections dont l'élection français ce
lien et les p -o a juste avant et les
pays-bas jusqu'avant qui ont montré
qu'en effet les citoyens face à un choix
prenez le choix de celui qui était le
plus européen et donc il
il essaye de montrer que lui veut faire
des choses en tant que chef de la
commission mais que la commission en
n'étant qu'un parmi d'acteurs parmi
d'autres il invite le parlement européen
à être aussi audacieux que lui et
apprendre en effet dès le relais et j'ai
les états les états membres parce que
les états membres on se souvient
toujours en pareil faut toujours se dire
que l'europe et les prérogatives que la
commission a ne sont que celles que les
états veulent lui donner
et donc quand on dit il n'ya rien en
matière sociale ou il ya rien en matière
fiscale c'est parce que jusqu'à présent
les états avaient garder le magot
fiscale et donc le plus gros frein de
l'europe ce sont bien sûr les états et
là il dit consignes et maintenant voilà
on va on va les ja happ les règles pour
justement permettre d'avancer j'ai
trouvé c'était aussi très schumannien
parce que la méthode des petits pas
allons-y dans plusieurs secteurs dans
les grands secteurs la commission
s'arrogent le droit de parler de ce qui
intéresse les gens au niveau européen le
reste - mais faisons départ conceptuel
avancer sur un certain nombre de points
économique sociale fiscale sécuritaire
diplomatique
on est dans un monde où l'europe comme
l'a rappelé isabelle et une première
puissance économique c'est pas la
première puissance du monde parce que au
niveau militaire là pour le coup les
etats-unis nous écrase mais on a un rôle
à jouer et si on le joue pas et bien les
partenaires et rivaux vont prendre la
main alors que nous on dit armand la
première de l'affirmer ce rôle sur les
questions militaires sur les questions
de climat entre vautrin philippe ricard
est ce que pour autant vous diriez
qu'ils n'en aient fini de la décennie
noire de l'union européenne et que ce
discours volontariste sera suffisant
pour relancer un peu ce nouveau souffle
ce sera simplement pas suffisante non
c'est qu'un discours de même que le
discours des mêmes macro ont récemment
athènes n'était qu'un discours donc des
grands
mis sur une situation qui est quand même
assez assez difficile voilà ceci dit un
vrai moment européen qui est à nouveau
là il ya une convergence et un état
d'esprit qui à nouveau un petit peu plus
optimiste que ça n'a été le cas au coeur
des crises que vous rappeliez en fait ce
qui est frappant aussi c'est que je
pense que les européens réagissent de
telle façon d'abord parce que après tout
ces crises ils sont encore debout
ils ont chancelé ils ont failli
s'éclater au moins au niveau de la zone
euro ou en a vu le brésil aussi qui est
quand même un signe de démantèlement d'
union européenne qui était complètement
inédit est très ressenti sans donc les
et les européens en chancelant mais sont
toujours debout
et puis ils voient ce qui les entoure
dans le monde il voit à l'élection de
donald trump qui est quand même qui a un
agenda en parti d'extrême droite devenu
certaine façon qui fait douter ses
alliés européens
donc les les européens face aux menaces
disant russe vous face à l'instabilité
au turc par exemple se disent c'est
maintenant à nous de nous organiser
réellement on est toujours debout il
faut essayer de faire en sorte qu'on
conçoit franchement requinquer mais tout
ça ne sont que des mots il ya toujours
des divergences très forte entre les
capitales c'est quand même à elle de
donner le ton effectivement les
institutions finalement suivront même si
monsieur juncker essaie de donner un
petit peu son agenda pour les pour les
prochains mois ben justement on va
décrypter un petit peu ses principales
annonces et vous vous évoquiez un sens
et questions institutionnelles
il en a été beaucoup question dans la
campagne française n'est plus largement
sur cette nécessité de refonder l'europe
de redonner un petit peu de souffle
démocratique et il est revenu sur cette
idée d' incarner l'europe de manière un
peu plus large
on écoute il nous faut ministres
européens de l'économie et les finances
un ministre européen qui soutiendrait
des réformes structurelles positive dans
nos états membres
il pourra se fonder sur le travail que
la commission a effectué depuis 2015
fallait que son unité dédiée au soutien
des réformes structurelles
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances devraient coordonner tous les
instruments de financement de l'union
qui doivent être mises en place pour
qu'un état membre puisse se sortir d'une
crise grave où une période de récession
je ne voudrais pas que l'on créé un
nouveau poste
je demande pour des raisons d'efficacité
que le commissaire chargé de l'économie
et les finances mondiales serait d'en
faire un vice président de la commission
européenne devienne lisse et soit
également le vice président de l'engrais
et on pense qu'il pascal janin est ce à
dire que pierre moscovici va devenir le
super puissant ministre des finances de
l'économie de la zone euro
2 le président de l'eurogroupe à ce que
c'est plausible est ce que c'est jouable
sans changer les traités
alors si la volonté des états membres
le souhaite il faut quand même vérifier
que l'allemagne est bien d'accord sur ce
point
il en sort à sac après le 25 septembre
vous aider un peu plus loin en fonction
de la coalition qui sera celle désignée
et puis de toute façon le temps que se
mette en oeuvre je pense que le mandat
de pierre moscovici sera en effet ça
serait aujourd'hui si cette disposition
existe et ce sera un des fils le
commissaire qui donc chargé d'économie
des finances au sein de la commission
qui serait aussi me présente de
regrouper ministre des finances a une
certaine une certaine cohérent parce que
il a aussi dit qu'il fallait jumelées ou
du moins faire en sorte que le convainc
commission européenne et le conseil
européen ne passe plus qu'un c'est une
icône et un seul numéro de téléphone
l'europe s'est passé même pas l'aider
c'est même pas ça c'est quand vous
regardez les sommets internationaux qui
existent ya toujours un parce que nous
ne sommes pas un état ya toujours un
représentant du pays donc c'est la
russie le japon les états unis le canada
et puis en face on a en effet trois
généralement par atteint européen quand
vous avez le sommet du g7 où le sait pas
un état mais l'union et représentez vous
avez la commission et le conseil pareil
auger va donc peut-être en effet que ça
permettrait en effet de donner davantage
de lisibilité à new york m à l'ignoble
et est donc en effet ça fait partie de
cette architecture nouvelle
alors moi j'suis pas dès que je peux je
crois pas qu'ils aient dit qu'ils
voulaient refonder l'europe parce que
quand vous l'avez écouté il a dit vous
ne savent rien de refaire le toit il
faudra faire des étages c'est pas les
fondations qui sont à refaire
c'est en effet la construction de
nouvelles pièces d'agrandir et de 2,2 de
bétonner peut-être en effet des choses
qui ne sont pas pour qu en effet comme
l'histoire des trois petits cochons six
ans lui fait des vents qui deviennent la
maison soit solide
il a parlé également du parlement de la
zone euro une idée que emmanuel macron
avait notamment porté mais comme
françois hollande en son temps
il l'a retoqué la fermez le ban le
parlement de la zone euro c'est le
parlement européen philippe ricard est à
dire que la france réd suez très isolés
cette association que emmanuel macron
lui et défend l'idée d'un parlement
nationaux mais sans trop préciser en
fait si c'est une nouvelle institution
si c'est une chambre sein du parlement
on sait pas trop en tous les cas son mot
effectivement c'est un parlement la zone
euro-- c'est une idée qui ne plaît pas
manifestement bien sûr aux
parlementaires européens également
désigné devant lequel nous soyons coeur
qui est très proche en fait du parlement
qui s'appuient souvent sur le parlement
européen pour faire passer ses projets
de directives mettrait effectivement les
arcades et donc monsieur juncker prend
clairement le parti du parlement
européen tel qu'il est actuellement
contre cette idée d'un parlement autre
alternative disons de la zone euro en
fait en réfléchissant pour lui c'est
assez naturel d'essayer d'éviter de
recréer une nouvelle institution dans la
mesure où à terme dit il
et ça sera particulièrement vrai à
partir de mars 2019 et le wise it
en fait la zone euro hélas non zone euro
et l'ue ou telle qu'elle vaut quasiment
se confondre les états qui ne sont pas
membres de l'euro avec le départ du
royaume uni vont être toujours les même
s'il y aura la pologne la hongrie et
cetera mais qui sont des états qui ont
l'obligation un moment où l'autre quand
ils sont prêts et quand ils le voudront
bien politiquement de rejoindre la zone
euro et puis leur poids économique
politique etc sera sera très marginale
on peut dire par rapport au bloc de la
zone euro donc décidé de dissocier et
d'aller vers cette europe à deux
vitesses je pense que un peu comme à
berlin
monsieur juncker s'en méfie terriblement
alors justement là on le voit bien il
l'a dit
la bulgarie la roumanie fin d'autres
pays son avocat sion en fait à rejoindre
la rejoindre la zone euro tout comme à
rejoindre schengen est ce que ce n'est
pas avec jégouzo enterré donc ce projet
d'europe à deux vitesses dont on a
beaucoup entendu parler mais c'est en
fait tenir tenir compte que du fait que
si on veut être
on veut exister au niveau international
il l'a très bien dit dans son discours
il faut qu'on soit uni il a dit aussi
l'or lors dans le livre blanc sur
l'avenir de l'europe où il explique que
pour faire face aux enjeux actuels
il faut que l'europe soit uni est ce que
la commission cherche à faire et que le
président jonckheere a très clairement
exprimé exprimé ce matin c'est faire en
sorte qu' il y ait dans cette union d'un
principe de liberté un principe
d'égalité entre tous et ce principe
d'égalité entre tous ça veut dire qu'il
n'ya pas de petit état de grands états
il y à des citoyens européens qui ont
tous les mêmes droits
donc ils vont tous pouvoir bénéficier de
l'euro qui vont tous pouvoir bénéficier
de la zone schengen et donc on aura une
europe à la fois plus unis c'est ce qui
l'a dessinée et plus lisible et plus
lisible c'est exactement ce que vient de
de décrire les prix car le le budget de
la zone euro une fois que l'union
europe et une fois que le royaume uni
sera sortie de l'union européenne c'est
à peu près 80 % du budget de l'union
donc c'est d'utilité finalement apte à
graissessac le contre et le beaucoup de
plus beaucoup de sens
on a intérêt au contraire avoir quelque
chose de beaucoup plus lisible de
beaucoup plus uni avec une europe qui
est capable de parler aussi d'une seule
voix avec cette idée du président unique
pour le les européens et la commission
alors emmanuel macron alors le le
président de la commission en fait c'est
a ensuite admis que les listes
transnationales elle l'idée du speed
seule candidate était une bonne idée
tout comme les conventions démocratique
un emmanuel macron lui a répondu sur
twitter merci de votre soutien
jean claude juncker pour l'organisation
de convention démocratique nous allons
réussir à transformer l'europe donc
c'est une petite victoire pour l'instant
pour le président français même si pour
le reste on verra ce que ça donne bien
entendu il ya eu d'autres annonces
on est revenu longuement enfin le
président de la commission est revenu
longuement sur la question centrale du
détachement des travailleurs qui
occupent les institutions et les pays
depuis déjà plusieurs années aurait
écoute l'union entre égaux il peut y
avoir de travailleurs de deuxième classe
ce qui fit eu le même travail au même
endroit doit pouvoir obtenir le même
salaire
[Applaudissements]
la commission a en ce sens ce fait des
propositions sur le détachement des
travailleurs
nous devrions veiller à ce que toutes
les dispositions de l'union concernant
la mobilité des travailleurs soient
justes efficaces et imposé par ce groupe
avec le soutien d'une nouvelle autorité
européenne de contrôle et d'exécution de
ces mesures
il est absurde s'il est une autorité
bancaire qui veille à ce que les normes
bancaires sont respectés dans un ami qui
n'y pas d'autorités heures des communes
du marché de l'emploi assurant la
justice sur le marché intérieur est ce
que c'est une bonne nouvelle cette prise
de contrôle par la commission potentiel
si toutefois on crée ce bureau de de
contrôle donc du travail des tâches est
ce que ça peut fonctionner fait des prix
car on verra si ça peut fonctionner il
faut d'abord voir si les états sont
capables de se mettre d'accord pour
déléguer peut-être une partie du
contrôle aux autorités européennes
j'attends un petit peu tard parce qu'on
voit très bien que cette question du
contrôle des travailleurs notamment
détachées c'est une question éminemment
souveraine enfin c'est elle divise
je ne vois pas bien les polonais délégué
ce genre de contrôle à bruxelles par
exemple quand on voit le bras de fer qui
actuellement avec la france sur la
question
donc c'est ça montre en tous les cas que
ce donc qu'un partage relativement le
sentiment de monsieur macron qu'il faut
approfondir la réforme et la refonte de
la directive sur les trois fils avait
déjà dit un de toute façon l'état belge
et vous l'année dernière à travail égal
au même endroit salaire égal c'est quand
même un look what if de la commission
depuis longtemps on voit qu'il ya eu une
reprise en main de la part de la france
sur cette question
quitte même à être pas toujours très
correct vis-à-vis des institutions
européennes en disant que rien n'a été
fait jusque là
alors à travail égal salaire égal c'est
effectivement l'année dernière dans un
discours il l'a répété aujourd'hui
et on a cette directive travailleurs
détachés qui est sur la table dont on
espère qu'on va trouver un accord il a
aussi dit il faut que chacun fasse un
morceau du pont et donc pour qu'on
trouve un accord donc c'est important
que on atterrissent sans doute au mois
d'octobre et que l'on ait un accord sur
ces directives sur les travailleurs
détachés mais il va aussi un petit peu
plus loin il rajoute un élément il a
outre votre votre votre extrait là il a
mentionné très très fortement la
nécessité d'avancer sur le socle des
droits sous l'eau et l'eau pour que le
l'union européenne ne soit pas soit une
union sociale ne soit pas un lieu de
dumping social et 7,7 autorités qu'il
veut mettre en place
el assad en sondant son adn de faire en
sorte que le marché du travail en europe
fonctionne selon des règles qui soient
des règles équitables et qu'on arrête la
concurrence intra-européenne parce
qu'elle voit la sphère des principaux
enjeux en fait de cette fin d'année
oui parce qu'il faut toujours avoir
conscience que on a ce qu'est une
circulation des personnes et qu' il
faudrait pas qu'il ya un frein qui soit
mis sur cette libre circulation
les anglais l'ont invoqué pour fermer un
peu brutalement toutes formes toutes
parts avec l'europe
il ya en effet un projet sur la table et
au parlement européen
alors il ya en effet des discussions du
priorat les états à voir en effet
comment les états vont se mettre
d'accord sur ce texte
et c'est pas gagné j'avais l'impression
que les distorsions était assez minimes
avant qu emmanuel macron en rajoute une
couche je sais pas si la couche macron
était dans le bon sens le mauvais sens
mais en tout cas les parlementaires
européens qui avaient qui sont chargés
de ça il ya une députée européenne
française elisabeth morin-chartier
disaient qu'ils avaient pas loin d'un
accord
alors après il faut voir si en effet ce
pas loin c'est raisonnable pas mais on
en a besoin et c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est que jusqu'à présent
on n'avait pas trop avancer sur les
questions sociales parce que les états
ne voulait pas alors maintenant si en
effet la commission le parlement
européen et les états membres veulent
avancer
ils peuvent le faire et ça ça serait
quelque chose que c'est visible pour les
citoyens européens
alors ce sera à suivre bien entendu il
est revenu aussi sur la question de
l'état de droit
on connaît les problématiques à l'est de
l'europe notamment avec la pologne et la
hongrie
mais la question est plus est plus
inquiétante que la hongrie vont me
permettre
et il est revenu longuement aussi sur le
dossier turc a on voit que depuis
quelques mois la question en fait ce
fait criantes notamment des rapports
avec la turquie est ce que la turquie
s'éloigne on réécoute chaque fois pour
chaque pays candidat
il faut que l'état de droit l'injustice
et les valeurs fondamentales soient
respectés c'est une priorité
quatre cas ceci exclut pour l'instant
une adhésion de la turquie
les turcs à la turquie depuis quelques
temps de s'éloigner très vite de l'union
européenne à pas de géant
les journalistes des rédactions de
pouvoir s'illustrer musée gourmand
les journalistes ne peuvent pas se
retrouver en prison
[Applaudissements]
j'adresse aujourd'hui un appel un appel
aux responsables
libérez nos journalistes et pas que les
nôtres cessé d'insulter nous états
membres nos chefs d'état et de
gouvernement les traitant de fascistes
et de nazis isabelle jégouzo la turquie
est définitivement en fait coupé de
l'union européenne il a été très clair
il a dit que certaines choses ne sont
pas acceptables un ton c'est loin et
d'odette adroit on s'éloigne très
clairement de l'union européenne mais il
a aussi dit que la porte restait ouverte
pour de grands peuples turcs l'ont c'est
quand même assez difficile comme
position à tenir quand on sait à quel
point l'union européenne doit à la
turquie la résolution entre guillemets
même si ce terme est un peu galvaudé de
la crise des migrants un nom alors je
suis pas d'accord les turcs faisais
n'importe quoi et envoyé délibérément
lors leur migrants déclic on les
rappelle à l'ordre
elle pas et après dans l'autre côté on a
signé un accord qui permet enfin de
renvoyer ce qui arrive en europe en
turquie contrevenants aussi en fait aux
textes internationaux sur la protection
des données bien on a un bénéfice de
corps à corps c'est d'ailleurs cet
accord a permis en effet de aux grecs de
souffler enfin les migrants il arrive
maintenant par par la méditerranée
centrale bien l'italie et de lui on non
il a raison de dire ça parce que quand
on parle d'élargissement les gens sont
absolument content parce qu'il est la
turquie est donc en effet il a parlé des
balkans mais on les balkans ils sont
absolument invisible quand on parle de
l'élargissement et il faut donc bien
séparer les choses
je pense qu'en effet les perspectives
d'élargissement pour les balkans oui on
sera plus de 27 1 jour mais en moins
dans au moins dix ans par contre pour la
turquie c'est comme être la russie il
faut mettre en place un partenariat
privilégié stratégique ce que vous
voulez mais lucide a déjà une vocation
et d'ailleurs je ne suis pas sûr qu
lecture voudraient rentrer finalement
parce qu'ils n'en perdrait beaucoup de
leurs politiques
dante et jean-pierre jeu au pied pire
car en fait juncker a parlé comme ça
parce que madame merkel il ya une petite
semaine dit d'arrêter des négociations
d'adhésion à l'union européenne donc
d'un débat en allemagne maintenant ça
sans me faire confiance tout ce qu'il
faut stopper ces négociations un peu
comme en autriche d'ailleurs je crois
que toute la classe politique
autrichienne aussi qui est très en
pointe sur le sujet est d'accord pour
dire ça ça reste quand même une question
ouverte au niveau européen je ne suis
pas tout à fait persuadé que tout le
monde en guadeloupe à madame merkel et
monsieur foule sur la question notamment
en france il m'a semblé entendre que du
côté de gouvernement ne vendent que du
côté de l'elysée on avait tendance à
dire il faut quand même poursuivre
autant que possible parce que les
négociations d'adhésion de la turquie il
faut bien voir que c'est pas l'adhésion
après demain évidemment que ça ça paraît
totalement est très très lent etc
mais c'est quand même un levier qu'on a
pour parler aux turcs et faire en sorte
qu'ils restent arrimés au monde
occidental on va dire lors qu'ils sont
et puis il joue un rôle incroyable dans
leur région donc et puis c'est un pays
mine de rien qui fait des efforts aussi
de modernisation ou on sent bien qu'il
ya une lutte entre des démocrates et des
dons d'un contrat etc
je suis pas sûr que ça soit une
amélioration mais c'est bien sûr que ça
ne s'améliore pas mais c'est pas
nécessairement non plus on leur fermant
la porte que ça va s'améliorer davantage
encore donc évidemment c'est une lutte
et là dedans dans cette lutte l'europe a
intérêt à être présente et on est
présent actuellement par le biais des
négociations d'adhésion
on peut très bien trouver d'autres
leviers ya pas de soucis mais il faudra
trouver quelque chose pour parler non
rien choses sur le partenariat
privilégié avec la turquie
c'est sur la table on peut enfin la sq l
on va peut-être imaginer avec les
touches le partenariat privilégié qu'on
est en train de construire la paix
la transition est toute trouvée il a
fallu attendre la 56e minute de discours
pour entendre parler du bric site
le brésil qui du coup n'est pas du tout
la priorité 1 pour jean claude juncker
donc et pour la commission il faut aller
de l'avant et pour le coup le break site
c'est plutôt en regardant en arrière on
écoute 20 9 mars 2019
le royaume uni qui tu là l'union
européenne ce sera à la fois un moment
triste et tragique nous le regretterons
toujours et vous le regretterez bantous
mais nous devons respecter la volonté du
peuple britannique
mais nous allons avancer nous allons
avancer parce que le break site l'uefa
tout parce que le break ce n'est pas le
but l'europe
nous allons avancer car le break si tu
n'es pas le futur de l'europe c'est à
dire que du coup ce n'est même plus un
sujet isabelle jégouzo ça reste un sujet
il ya une négociation qui est piloté par
michel barnier avec quelques difficultés
avancées avec des difficultés à avancer
mais avec aussi un calendrier qui est
très clair et avec une europe unie
les 27 sont unis feront il ya une
méthode de négociations il ya des sujets
qui sont qui sont sur la table et on va
avancer
est ce qu a très clairement dit le
président sait que l'europe le l'avenir
de l'europe n'est pas là et l'avenir de
l'europe il a il a dessiné par ailleurs
bon dans son discours 29 mars 2010neuf
donc date de sortie des britanniques de
l'union européenne est ce à dire que
d'ici là en fait tout peut arriver
y compris de revoir potentiellement en
fait d'autres d'autres petits îlots
comme ça quitter l'union européenne ont
vraiment c'est derrière nous cette seule
phrase je crois que en effet les
britanniques qui avaient une position
quand même toujours un peu particulière
remonte pas hésité à moitié dedans et à
moitié dehors
vont être dehors avec vouloir peut-être
un pied dedans parce que ce qui était ce
qu'il y règne aujourd'hui c'est comme la
confusion de la position britannique
j'ai l'impression qu'ils veulent sortir
ça c'est clair
mais comment alors est-ce qu'on sort de
tous est ce qu'on reste dans le marché
unique est ce qu'on reste dans la
coopération de défense à ce qu'on
bénéficie encore de certaines choses qui
nous arrange eux mêmes en fait ne sont
pas très l'intérieur du parti
conservateur et canada partout que
d'amateurs il ya beaucoup de dissensions
etc en effet c'est pas un sujet pour les
européens
ils vont sortir le 29 mars 2019 ce que
ces deux ans après la vocation de
l'article 50 sorties en effet y avait un
tremblement de terre politique
britannique qui fasse conquis dès qu'ils
ne sortent pas qui ce qui n'est pas
impossible mais voilà donc l'avenir
c'est sans les britanniques et donc on
en parle moi philippe ricard en 10
secondes
est ce qu'aujourd'hui avec la question
du bric site finalement n'est plus un
sujet pour l'union européenne
en fait c'est surtout un sujet pour le
royaume uni ce problème par unis qui lui
est en pleine déflagration alors qu'on
pensait il ya un an au moment du vote en
faveur du président que c'est l'europe
qui était sur le point des deux
banquiers c'est pas le cas du tout c'est
ça qui est assez frappant c'est un peu à
fronts renversés par rapport au crâne
bien non bon bah écoutez on suivra merci
à vous de nous avoir permis de décrypter
ce discours sur l'état de l'union du
président juncker
très belle suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires et à très vite
sur ces questions européennes
[Musique]
à